Ron darling back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Ron I'm doing great
rich thanks for having me back on all
always love a chat with you Ron let's
let's get right into it I despised the
shift and I think it is causing more
strikeouts in the game Ron I I think
more and more guys are trying to hit it
over it or hit it harder through it and
and and they're not skilled enough quite
frankly to put the bat on the ball I'm
wondering what you think yeah I'm
absolutely with you with this you know
if you're trying to speed up the game
have guys put squalane more trying to
keep the game more like the integrity of
the game I think it would be great to
keep I don't see there's been shifting
forever okay a second baseman will shift
in a little different position depending
on what's going to be thrown but to be
able to put eight people on one side of
the baseball aesthetically it looks ugly
it's not fun to watch and it doesn't
serve a purpose absolutely every kid
that six years old now we'll never get a
base hit on the ground to the right side
of the infield is still a left-handed
hitter so that's it what they want to
create then that's certainly what they
created but the answer I get back
whenever I'm railing about it is that
well then these guys should hit them
where they ain't but I don't think Casey
Stengel said bottom where they ain't
like that's not that's not what I want
to see a power hitter do Ron that's you
know yeah and I think also you know I
think that and anyone says you know hit
it the other way probably has not tried
to make a living and hitting you know
it's a very difficult thing to do and to
be able to say hey you know they're
they're playing on this side so I'm just
going to hit a ground ball to the
shortstop hole well that just it's not
easy to do it's a very difficult thing
to do so you know you hope that at the
ground level you know between 10 years
old 12 years old whatever they're being
taught maybe they'd hit the ball come
close to cozy like Pele by the
left-field line but I doubt it I think
what we could is is that we're going to
pay you if you can strike people out and
we're gonna pay you if you can hit the
ball over the fence and so
players that are being taught how to
play today are being taught in that way
so what do you think the fix is do you
think I'll let me put it this way do you
think of this as necessary Ron I I think
a fix is necessary in the sense that I
don't see a sport staying as popular or
getting more popular that's really what
you're trying to do right with so much
inactivity there's just not enough
happening within a baseball game unless
you catch one of those rare ones where
there's a lot of happening to keep the
attention I think of the new fan now
listen guys my age they're going to
watch baseball until they're in a box
right because they love the little
nuances of the game even though it's
change they can still find enough in
there to pique their interest but for
the big fan who who wants to see some
folks beat each other to a pulp or wants
an instant action and all that kind of
stuff
baseball certainly is not providing it
right now Ron darling here on the Rich
Eisen show how much are the Dodgers in
trouble or do you think that there's
still enough baseball left here Ron well
there's definitely enough faceful left
and they've got you know the foundation
of really talented players that can turn
this around now let's not forget they
got off to a slow start last year but
they went 53 and 9 over a 62 game
stretch that's probably not going to
happen again right so I think the
problem you have with the Dodgers is you
know the obvious ones you know you're
missing Turner you miss eager on the
left side of your defense and offense
that that hurts but you also have some
guys that had years like they never
really anticipated not the Dodgers or
the or the players themselves with Chris
Taylor and Cody Bellinger and trying to
match that it's a very difficult thing
to do their best pitcher maybe the best
pitcher in the game is out there there's
a lot of a lot of things working against
them that being said they still have
some really good players I think Arizona
saw a favor by coming back to the pack
so
you know there is plenty of time but you
know when you're watching your team and
your team's playing you know well then
you say hey we're gonna have a shot but
yeah I think anyone was watching the
Dodgers right now it's not seeing that
both could have to be a radical shift in
how they're playing the game well in
terms of the Dodgers woes this weekend
the Reds who couldn't do anything right
come in sweep in four games now they're
just I have only two fewer wins than the
Dodgers have all year and Matt Harvey
was part of the positives how bizarre
was it for you to see Matt Harvey in a
red uniform well the most bizarre part
of it I think for me was when he had the
interview with the Bengals the
Cincinnati press might have been the
National Press and and and Boyd it was
like a weight had been lifted off him he
didn't even seem like the same person
that had been with the Mets the last
couple of years where you know he had
for whatever reason many reasons a cloud
kind of hanging over his performance and
himself you know listen I'm happy for
him I want him to be a great player
again because the sport was better when
he was the Dark Knight but he's gonna
have to be a little different and you
know taking that alpha male macho
pitcher and making him into a different
kind of pitcher has been tried by many
and there's only a few that get through
and it's it's because of how hard it is
to make that transition and and you
couple that with a couple of surgeries
that he's had also you know he's got a
lot of work ahead of him I think having
some new eyeballs and and and someone
else to talk to about how to get there I
think is a positive thing for him and
you know Cincinnati is a let's say it's
a quieter town and it'll allow him to
maybe work on his craft
as much as he needs a few more minutes
with Ron darling here on the Rich Eisen
show in your history of being in
fascinating clubhouses Ron and being
around others as a professional
broadcaster where does David Price not
being able to throw allegedly because he
played too many video games with his
pitching high rank
for you Ron where does it yeah yeah
that's up there with the with the
burning yourself ironing the shirt on
your body that's a story I heard the
pulling on of the hurting Andy by
pulling on the cowboy boot my I've heard
just about all of them but it does kind
of make sense you know and videogames
are very important to a lot of young
players and or older players price has
been around for a long time but to have
carpal tunnel and it affect your
pitching to me is is is is one I hadn't
heard before it was there an Atari in
the Shea locker room or something like
that
Ron no no it's no Ataris the guys of my
generation played cards that was their
thing cards from the second I got in the
clubhouse too sometimes after the games
so I guess the shuffling of the cards
and the dealing of the cards a less wear
and tear on the fingers it was the best
card player you ever played with then oh
the best card player I think that Kevin
McReynolds was probably the best card
player yeah because he was just he's one
of those guys Toto face he couldn't tell
right hope he could you could not tell
he had a poker face and I think the the
best thing that he had is that he
usually had the showdown with a Lenny
Dykstra so there was a definitely a comp
competitive edge for Kevin oh come on
now they got it give me give me a little
bit more meat on that bones would I they
just would play gin and they'd play gin
and play gin out and let's just say that
major checks exchanged hands at the end
of every seasons and it's usually Kevin
and his family you ended up with a nice
new car well I guess you know while
we're on the subject in the Supreme
Court allowing sports betting and the
state level from what it seems like how
do you think that's going to affect
Major League Baseball we had one caller
call and wondering if that might change
Pete Rose's fortune by the end of the
day yeah I don't think it's gonna change
Pete Rose's fortune um
because of the certain rules that were
in place then but you know you know rich
I'm always you know these state
governments are so mismanaged and ill
run that anytime they can get a revenue
source it's almost like who really cares
about the collateral damage let's just
get this in place so we can get some
money and I I think that there's so many
layers to this I mean that's my first
thought that I had was that a lot of
people are going to think because LeBron
James other people they make so much
money that they would never be tempted
by the gambler but what about the
journeyman a wide receiver who was in
his last year and hasn't really made it
has an option of catching the ball and
not catching the ball if he's of that
ilk those are the things that I think
about when I think about just allowing
this to happen unfettered unthought
about and and and and not talk through
and so is it gonna hurt the integrity of
sport well I I would say that there's
more of a chance now than there was
before last one for Iran
we had Keith Hernandez on the other day
yeah and he is he's a Twitter fiend
right now Ron I mean his cat [ __ ] is a
star and I'm wondering how that sits
with with you the rest the SNY crew and
obviously somebody who played with Keith
for all those years
Ron well let me just say the the guy
that I work with now so I think I played
was I played with was was a was an
amazing player very serious about his
craft he has become incredibly funny
open and and I'm sure he talked about
his new book that's coming out I've read
it already and it gonna have to pick it
up it's a it's it's it's a great kind of
story not only this family but also know
how hard it is to become a major league
player he became an MVP player but his
internet sensation is this is what I
love about social media is that and I
think Keith would agree hopefully he'd
agree
he has absolutely no idea what he's
doing on social media and he's become a
star so I think that's what that to me
is the bottom line is that he is just in
it and got in it and the next thing you
know he's a star and he wouldn't be able
to tell you the first reason why but I
think it's because he's just an original
personality I've never met anyone like
him and and I think people enjoy his
take on everything the end yet you're
not so inspired to getting your own
Twitter situation wrong right I I don't
know I I just feel like it's it's my
first bounce pass into unemployment to
play the truth which I think I'm I'm
definitely afraid of social media doubt
I'll get on it and I'll follow people
like yourself to get some information
and all that kind of stuff but as far as
participating with the back and forth
with fandom or or friends or whatever
that honestly scares me to death
I'm not a complete misanthrope but you
know I have tendencies so the social
media would not be much my fav see I
mean and then what Keith's doing with it
kind of blows up the axiom of like well
if you don't want to be social just get
a cat and he's done both and it's a cost
more social it's very strange wrong and
there's a lot of cat people out there I
didn't realize that Wow Ron I love our
chats you take care of we'll chat again
soon hopefully
awesome let's take care unionize Ron
darling the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience